it is one day until Mayweather and
McGregor touch eight ounce gloves and
thrilled to have to discuss that in our
Honda inside a report to kick off our
number three and if you're on hold stay
on hold we will take your calls here in
our three of the show at eight four four
two oh four rich is a long time boxing
historian and analyst of notes and a
raconteur of the first variety thrilled
to have here in person Larry Merchant
how are you Larry thank you and Phil to
be I really appreciate it so what are
your thoughts on mayweather mcgregor
we've heard so far ranging that this is
a real bout that this is a combat sport
event of note and we've heard it is a
mockery of what both of these guys can
do in their different size rings where
do you stand on this Larry they'd have
to pay me to watch it okay and a lot
more than $100 you're not interested in
seeing what happens in this I'm
interested in hearing what happens how
could you not be
and but it's just it's a spectacle and
all props to them for creating this
thing that's monstrous in all ways but I
don't know if you noted that the
association of ring physicians has
condemned it would like the Nevada
Commission to cancel it there was on a
lower level of the game an MMA fighter
who boxed a boxer and died in the ring
just a few months ago in Canada so it's
a mismatch of the highest order
I'm only surprised that they haven't
made it a fight to the death and that
might get my interest now in all
seriousness stuff Wow
but in it you really think McGregor is
putting his life on the line tomorrow
night I can't I can't go that far but
it's it
isn't reflects the chance he has I think
the odds opened at around twenty to one
and everybody who goes to Vegas and bets
and the wants to bet on the get the odds
and so this it's come down to me the
chance I give McGregor is that he's the
only one of eight billion people on the
planet who has a chance and so the odds
are about eight billion to one that he
would defeat Mayweather but what about
the idea of Larry Merchant here in the
Richardson show studio what about the
idea that he can catch him with that one
punch well that's the that's the one in
eight billion
and since Mayweather is a master of
defense and his first and second and
third priorities when he goes into the
ring is not to get hit that he's
fighting a guy who in the elite world of
boxing would be considered a rank
amateur there are different games you
know in one game the idea mostly is to
hit the other guy in the head and they
know how to punch the other game it's
it's it's generally takes a toll on the
body I know a physician who deals with
MMA guys and tells me how how their
tendons and can't stand the the the how
they get beaten up the rigors of yeah
it's it and but but they don't get hit
in the head the way price fighters do
and you know so if this bout were being
fought under MMA rules yes
I give mayweather the same chance of
beating McGregor as I give McGregor now
of beating Mayweather right and that was
our poll question today right Chris
Rahman that that's people are voting on
right now
what that's right if this fight were in
the Octagon would you be 46 percent say
more interested then there would be a
Larry Merchant here in the Rich Eisen
show studio I mean we reached out to
Lampley to talk about this he doesn't
even want to talk about he doesn't want
to talk about this fire I mean I and I
you know I'm looking at obviously a
purist
of somebody who has been looking at the
the boxing game for as long as you have
Larry does this at all equate to
anything that you've seen before
Mayweather this is an occasional movie
I've seen before like what what is it
Sarge of half a century ago or so and a
similar match which was declared an
exhibition not a real fight Shea Stadium
New York on an undercard of a big fight
Chuck Wepner the Bayonne bleeder the
Bayonne bleeder who later became famous
as the inspiration for Rocky mm-hmm what
Andre the Giant yes he was 74 and 380 or
whatever and in the second round he
picked Wepner up who was 6 4 and 240 and
threw him out of the ring literally and
of course there's Ali and enoki the
Japanese wrestler which turned out to be
a serious fraud because even the
Japanese fans in Tokyo booted because
Ali spent almost the whole time jumping
around the ring and climbing on the
ropes to get away from this guy and but
he made a pile of money and that's what
it's about McGregor has fought right he
has been a boxer before he went in today
I hear he was an amateur boxer
Larry Merchant here in the Rich Eisen
show in the Honda inside a rapport so
where does Floyd Mayweather rank
all time for you as a funny I'm not good
with lists okay I think he was one of
the best of his time which to me is high
praise he's the best pure boxer what do
you mean by that well by that he's his
discipline and and craft as a boxer who
is able to impose his boxing wizardry on
his opponents by not taking many risks
you could be sure that when a Mayweather
fight comes along the excitement stops
when the first bell rings he's not in
there to create thrills and drama that's
before the fight in the build-up to the
fight and he's a wizard at that too of
using modern media to market and promote
himself I give him the highest marks
being a very clever matchmaker for
himself as this indicates and making a
pile of money and I take nothing away
from him for that but in the big scheme
of things to me Pacquiao was the best
fighter of this time as opposed to boxer
and yet when he had his shot against him
though when he had his shot two fighters
near the end of their careers the boxer
one I'll tell you something the boxer
generally beats the fighter at the
highest levels when they have a showdown
just as Ward did recently when he fought
the Russians just as Tunney did when he
fought Dempsey but who do we remember
tiny or Dempsey mm-hmm right you
remember the one who raises their hands
in victory
you know don't you you remember the one
who created drama
that's what fans are there
a famous promoter matchmaker Madison
Square Garden once said to me there is
no room in price fighting in Cola boxing
price fighting for perfection yes
because if you if everyone fought like
Mayweather nobody would go there would
be no price fighting well here's what
I'd like to do Larry I'd like to take a
break
I'd like to since you believe this is on
the level of Chuck the Bayonne bleeder
Wepner versus Andre the Giant in the now
dearly departed Shea Stadium okay what
I'd like to do is figure out who is
going to win this fight Mayweather or
McGregor using the famed childhood game
Rock'em Sock'em robots okay I'm gonna do
that Larry it's on the championship
level exactly we're gonna do that del to
fo you will take one fighter I will take
the other and in this we're gonna do in
our television break and then you if you
don't mind you will come and do your
best to interview the winner of the
fight sure okay Larry merchants gonna do
that
and then when we come back I want to
talk about your 10:00 on Tet with
Mayweather in the ring after Victor
Ortiz back in 2011 and also walk through
a couple of the more outrageous prompt
bets of the fight and have you do that
okay
you got thank you that's Larry Merchant
by the way the Honda Insider reporters
brought to you by our friends at Honda
the new Honda Odyssey behind every
single little leaguer is a great home
team as we mentioned the family friendly
friendly Honda Odyssey makes your team
that much better it makes my team that
much better Honda is the official
vehicle of the Little League World
Series your phone calls eight four four
two oh four rich please stay on the line
we will do that still to come here in
our number three but we come back with
more with Larry Merchant here on the
Rich Eisen show
the Rock'em Sock'em robots this is gonna
predict who wins the fight Larry
Merchant have you ever seen a Rock'em
Sock'em robot demonstration before a
fight before and then called the match
have you ever done that before
never in my life but I'm up for
something new okay very good all right
here we go how do we know when the bell
goes somebody's got it ready but yes
three two one did you knock off Larry
come on in it was like come on
Mayweather has won the fight Larry
Merchant go for it how do you explaining
the fact that this fight went longer
than most of us expected it was amazing
I just came out I trained and I was
ready to go and I got him as soon as I
came out boom an uppercut right there
the fight was supposed to be at 154
pounds you look like you took a lot of
liquids before buffets were just way too
much for me in Vegas so all week I went
there thank you what would what would
have sarn't yes Conor so when did you
stop beating your wife
someone let you talk to Pictoris all
right I'm through they put somebody else
up and give me interview you never give
me a fair shake XP only to fire you you
know I wish I was 50 years younger and
I'd kick your ass that was June 7 2011
here we are on August 25th of 2017
getting set for Mayweather McGregor and
Larry Merchant in studio what a great
line Larry 15 50 years either you kick
his ass it was a spontaneous
counterpunch walk me through what what
what what happened there
in the ring with Floyd well it was a
controversial ending the referee lost a
little control walked away Ortiz is a
younger fighter follow the referee and
thought what's he doing and while he was
looking Mayweather clocked them it was a
legal sucker punch now as far as the
crowd was concerned much of it being for
Ortiz they just saw the sucker punch the
rules are not printed on the back of the
ticket and when I went to interview
Mayweather
after the fight the volatility in the
urn has extorted to get more and more
explosive and he sensed and he's really
smart about these kind of matters
immediately he knew he was not going to
get credit for what just happened and he
just blew up and it was a personal
attack what I said is kind of
unprofessional but human that if you
were 50 years younger you'd kick it yeah
well I must tell you that back in my
house where my wife was watching with a
friend
the conversation was all about whether I
should have said if I were sick
if fifty years younger instead of if I
was which is not correct oh I see they
had no problem with you wanting to step
in the ring with Floyd the grammar is
nice and as soon as I walked out of the
ring I knew this would be no lower than
second in my paragraph of my obituary
hmm and and by the time I was able to
fight through the crowd to get to dinner
with with some friends there were
t-shirts on the Internet merchants vs.
Mayweather so it it blew up you have a
tea - did you get one of those t-shirts
no somebody sent me a photo of one I'm
not a collector hmm so we've been able
to lay a glove on Mayweather better than
MacGregor Larry much love but I would
have snuck up behind him and kicked him
in the ass you are a crowd pleaser Larry
Merchant that's for damn sure
and Mayweather did he apologize to you
he later and a fight or two later he
came up to me and he apologized and I
thanked him for it and I told him
viewers after that fight that he had
done that and I thought I was being
gracious but then I was told that in the
press conference afterwards it he he
said that he showed he was more of a man
than me so you guys are in good terms
they said hey Larry there's there's some
Larry Merchant here in the Rich Eisen
show there are some more outrageous prop
bets I'd love to walk you through right
now and see if he gets on that and you
put this on the level of Andre the Giant
versus Chuck the Bayonne bleeder or or a
Kardashian kind of show famous for being
famous but no there there okay so here
we go
Mayweather McGregor prop bets with Larry
Merchant who will have more people with
them during the fight walk out
Mayweather
McGregor larry merchant uh McGregor
because my most of the fans are going in
the hopes that somehow Mayweather gets
his comeuppance okay
do you think Bieber's gonna be with
Floyd Mayweather what do you think I
heard they had a falling out as an
example of his cleverness yes he would
walk in with different kinds of rock
stars and so on and I understand that he
paid some of them and he got that this
was good self promotion being identified
with stars who's the best walkout you've
ever seen whoa I'm not sure uh you know
to me the best showman there ever was
was Ali yes but coming to a fight he was
you know fairly normal in those in those
moments but I've seen some you know I
love Pacquiao's walkins where he was
smiling and loving everybody and here he
is this kind of cerebral killer who's
gay and but I don't remember oh well of
course the one who turned the walk out
into a art form just was the British guy
Prince Naseem
and I remember who's Madison Square
Garden Kevin Kelly he had had some
sensational fights and a scene and I
don't remember exactly how he walked out
it might have been well wasn't it on a
magic carpet that was in London at that
time I said a lot of fans would like to
see him go all the way to Iceland but
when he came into the garden I said this
is the end of Western civilization as we
know it the best man well you know
Mayweather may use it as a trolling
opportunity so there's a question will
Nate Diaz walk out with Floyd Mayweather
yes or no what do you think
everything I know about this fight
there's astronomical odds okay so the
answer would be yes you think that's
going to happen there there is a a
prompt that causes us a Saturday the
number of tweets from the President of
the United States tomorrow the
over-under is six and a half tweets from
a trio Donald Trump do you go over or
under tomorrow Larry
I'm gonna go over because he he senses
you know he used to I met him when he
was promoting with Don King yes in
Atlantic City you know and if if Don
King had been a boy rich and white he
would be Donald Trump and if Donald
Trump were born poor and black he would
be Don King Larry merchants everybody
here on the Rich Eisen show argue well
either fight or lose their mouthpiece
during the fight yes or no only after
the fight okay so that will be a no who
will be the first fighter to bleed
mayweather or mcgregor
i think that the referee you might be
the first one to please and which fight
will be shorter mayweather mcgregor or
alvarez triple G what do you got on that
front may way then McGregor by you know
eight billion to one oh wow you're just
not high on this flight I'd love it
before I let you go Larry Merchant your
best ally story and I know that's uh
that's asking a lot but what are you
going for me
what's okay we're on the plane going to
[Music]
Zaire
the Congo for the Foreman fight and an
hour into the flight Ali goes into the
cockpit and gets on the loudspeaker and
starts doing a number on the fact that
both pilots are black and he's never
been in a plane with two black pilots
and he hopes they can find sire he comes
out he sits down next to me
and he says to me if he doesn't get me
in seven his parachute won't open
speaking of for mature because he knew
he intuited that the one weakness in in
this monster who was thought of as
unbeatable at the time was his stamina
and I think that understanding was what
led to the famous rope-a-dope that if he
could stay in there was long enough that
he would that Foreman would use himself
up and sure enough the eighth round Ally
knocked him out humbly we called a shot
with you Larry on the flight yes truly
unbelievable I mean I miss him every day
I've just always wondered what he would
be saying about everything with Colin
Kapernick or with what's going on in
Charlottesville his voice is missed I
felt like I was the the barking dog at
an endless parade I was there for many
of his fights Larry really appreciate
you coming on ready John it's it's an
honor thank you oh gosh please the honor
is all ours here on the show Larry
Merchant here on the Rich Eisen show we
are back in 60 seconds with your phone
calls eight four four two oh four rich
is the number to dial certainly for all
those folks have been kind enough to
hold throughout all of our in-studio
guests Larry you're the best things are
coming up the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to